logan webb on the hill tonight for the
giants webb 24 years of age
6-1 215 pounder
and for logan webb 10-3 on the year and
10-0 in this ballpark this year he's
pitched very very good
here at oracle park
on the ground right off the bat
lamont wade not a problem and that's how
this game gets started
he struck him out swinging he went to
the slider and he broke off a beauty
that broke down and in and out of the
strike zone runner goes
swinging a pop-up
side retired as brian puts it away
luke had an impressive return from
shoulder trouble earlier this month
candy but mixed results since then he's
lost three straight starts
yeah he's been scuffling a little bit
you know on the year you know three and
six but you know he's really had a tough
time on the road you know oh and four
with the 794 era
97 right by him
boy luke weaver is coming right at these
guys two batters and two strikeouts some
heat at 97.
shot into the gap
nobody's there
that's a 96 mile an hour fastball and
buster posey standing on second base
bryant has had four hits in 12 at bats
in the past against weaver
payoff pitch runners will be on the move
[Applause]
and he walked him two down and the base
is loaded but mike yostremski there they
go the pitch
too high and he has walked in a run
with his 36th hitch of the inning
longoria three for six lifetime against
weaver and guess what all three hits are
doubles
got him looking oh longoria barksman was
in the box he's still barking
as this is lying to left and a good jump
by bryant as he puts it away the one and
two pitch swing and a foul tip
in
that is the second strikeout
[Applause]
now here's a swinging strike three on a
good slider down and out of the strike
zone beauty
[Applause]
that one sneaks through just by listella
and mccarthy's aboard to start the third
and throw it away
wade gets hung up with mccarthy he's
around to second he's gonna fly for
third here comes the throw from
yustripski not in time
to base throwing error on logan webb and
now the d backs have the tying run 90
feet away
rojas gets it up in the air
bryant's got a big arm
mccarthy's at third here he comes and
he's in there we're tied up the rbi for
rojas and it's one one
got him febex tied up
[Applause]
wayne skies it to shortstop rojas
calling for it
[Applause]
crawford hits a change up to left shy of
the track peralta settles under it to
make the catch for out number two
got it under the hands just like you
wanted brian missed it
[Music]
here's his 1-2 marshall strikes out
swinging fastball 93 miles an hour
so now here's peyman smith a strikeout
victim in the first
[Music]
that one punched to short crawford
smothers it he's got no play
so they're loaded now just one out in
the inning and the batter is josh van
meter
here's the pitch van meter ground ball
to short crawford's got it he'll run to
the bag at second for one throw to first
got him double play huge for logan webb
and the giants
swinging a drive to right
hit well off the bricks
jazwa headed to second base and he's got
a double
[Applause]
here's a good change up
and he gets out number one that's
strikeout number six for luke
the third duggar to second and it brings
up tommy la stella here
chopped out in front of the plate
varshall is on it and luke weaver
survives he strands two
and through four we're still tied at one
he goes
on the ground
crawford's got it
and they get the out at first on a nice
play and holding at second is mccarthy
nice play
[Applause]
right to crawford he gets the mound and
hits
a big hop the 21st pitch of this inning
from webb he winds and throws a slow
bouncer to second castella comes in to
get it here's the throw to first
in time for the out
and he gets through it
caleb smith gets the strikeout martay
does not feel the bet
see this used to be an olympic event the
bat toss
all the way up to cattell
tried the background that he was in
position
giants are over three with runners in
scoring position and here's an
opportunity for us
that's a care from three sliders see you
later caleb smith strands too listella
an rbi opportunity he had one in the
fourth and he ended up dribbling one out
in front of home plate here it is
swing and there's a soft liner in the
right field just over the head of marte
base hit mongolia had to freeze to make
sure that it was going to be over the
head of marta then
took off the third and now the bases are
loaded and here comes wilmer
line drive base hit it'll score one
dickerson again will be held at third
giants take the lead and that's how you
make a lead off air hurt the cozy two
for three in the game with a 303 average
for the year
and the 3-1 pitch
posey takes low ball four he has walked
in a run dickerson will cross the plane
now it is three to one giants base is
loaded one out two runs in for the
giants and brandon crawford will be the
hitter here
crawford breaks his bat he's got a base
here and again the runners had to hold
to make sure that it was not caught
coming in to score is solano 4-1 giants
bases will stay loaded and the hitter
will be slater
in the dirt to the backstop buster posey
scores it's five to one
now they'll let mccarthy remain in the
game and face the lefty
mccarthy gets one in the air hits deep
to left field and that ball is gone jake
mccarthy opposite field diamondbacks
answer back and it's five to two but
that lefty on lefty they left the left
on left match up in there and mccarthy
took him deep deep out to left tyro
estrada will come up as the pinch hitter
now
and another one to the back stop and
another run scores wow
another gift
old calhoun singled into fourth he's one
through three
1-1 calhoun lines one down the left
field line it's fair and it will go all
the way to the warning track one run
will score on his way to third is var
show calhoun has to hold it first with a
long single and it's an rbi base hit and
the d-backs now trail six to three
and that's a lot of slug that's missing
peralta drives it deep to right center
slater runs it down varsho can tag and
it's 6-4 the rbi for david
berdomo drives it deep to center field
geraldo perdomo hits off the wall
and perdomo's at second
here's josh rojas last man standing he
doubled and scored his last time up
got him
he throws a slider down and in posie to
first and that's the ball game and
that's his first big league save
[Applause]
[Music]